My sister and my niece
Gogo are flying all the way over from Utah today
and I know that they love chocolate muffins,
so I decided to make them some before they arrive.
I combined some all purpose flour,
Dutch process cocoa, salt,
sugar,
and some chopped up chocolate before moving on to my wet ingredients,
which are some eggs, milk,
sour cream, olive oil,
and some vanilla. I gave that a good whisk
and then poured my wet ingredients into my dry.
I made sure to not over mix it.
As soon as it came together,
I spooned it into my muffin tin
that was lined with some Parchment paper.
Top my muffins with more chocolate
before popping them in the oven for about 15 minutes
while I got started on my chocolate ganache.
I heated up a smidge of heavy cream,
chopped up some more milk chocolate
before pouring the hot heavy cream over it.
Let that sit for about two minutes before whisking it all together.
Since I wanted to fill my muffins with my chocolate ganache,
I transferred it over to a squeeze bottle,
pulled my muffins out, let them cool for about 10 minutes,
and then filled every single one of my muffins
with that melted chocolate.
In order to keep them fresh,
I transferred them over to my dome cake plate
and waited for them to arrive.